moi je vais vous dire les choses comme
je les pense avec avec la liberté que la
mienne et d'ailleurs y compris sûre que
j'ai toujours eu sur ce plateau on vous
a jamais dit de dire que ok sur ce
plateau vous pouvez essayer y compris
monsieur Bolloré je crois pas qu'il
contrôle le cerveau de personne voilà
pas davantage celui de Monsieur Drahi ou
de Monsieur Bouygues exactement personne
ne doit je vais chez tout le monde mais
je vais je vais vous dire les choses
avec liberté sincérité
j'ai regardé ça j'ai découvert sur les
réseaux sociaux réseaux sociaux après
coup cette vidéo je l'ai regardé en
entier voilà j'ai regardé à peu près 10
minutes d'accord c'est un échange et le
sentiment que j'ai eu je pense que c'est
celui qu'on a eu beaucoup de de de
téléspectateurs c'était à la fois gênant
et même dérangeant parce que c'est parti
voilà avec des insultes c'est toujours
dérangeant quand il y a deux personnes
c'est avec qui
ça sert et vous dire les choses je pense
qu'effectivement voilà fallait pas le
faire on peut pas se permettre
d'insulter j'ai entendu que vous
regrettiez des choses
je suis pas là pour vous dire qu'il faut
s'excuser je me permettrai pas mais je
pense que les téléspectateurs et les
Français qui vous regardent et qui vous
ont toujours regardé peut-être qu'on
peut leur dire peut-être pouvez-vous
leur dire que vous êtes désolé de ce qui
s'est passé et que effectivement
je respecte plus le public peut-être que
les institutions et ça c'est ce qui
voilà et toujours après ce que cette
affaire sur cette séquence de télévision
révèle aussi pour moi
c'est aussi ce discours qui me paraît de
plus en plus cynique hypocrite de la
part de la France insoumise et je crois
qu'avec lui boyards moi d'après ce que
j'ai compris ça gêne Mélenchon et la
nomenclature de de de la France
insoumise ils sont pas exprimés biboyar
a fait une conférence de presse j'ai
trouvé j'étais quand même étonné de voir
que le garçon ce jeune député était seul
à la tribune d'habitude il y a toujours
un groupe de LFI qui entoure et
franchement avoir été chroniqueur
rémunéré et venir ensuite on ne peut pas
imaginer qu'il n'a pas voulu chercher
dans un pré méditer ce qu'il allait
faire je trouve que c'est le comble du
cynisme quand on sait que Garrido est
venu ici comme chroniqueuse qui s'en
doute a été rémunéré quand on sait que
c'est normal pense insoumise a été parmi
les premiers partis politiques à être
invité ce laisser inviter
contrairement aux parties socialiste par
exemple qui a souvent ou moi j'avais des
camarades qui refusaient souvent
voilà je trouve que c'est un discours
qui révèle à la fois les excès la
démesure et surtout l'impuissance de la
France insoumise qui est prête à toutes
les critiques mais qui a aussi prête à
manger dans la main du système pour
ensuite critiquer le système et je
trouve que c'est déplorable pour un
homme de gauche comme moi de voir une
gauche aussi bête aussi impuissante qui
uniquement n'a que dans son jeu le
spectacle du cirque et je pense que ce
type de comportement dégrade la vie
politique après moi c'est vrai qu'on a
entendu des mots à l'Assemblée nationale
une président de groupe LFI m'a-t-il
panneau alors qu'elle a écouté la
première ministre dire qu'elle était
fille de rescaper que son père s'est
suicidé alors qu'elle était jeune enfant
et venir dire rescaper etc sans avoir
aucune sorte de d'empathie peut-être en
jouant la provocation je pense ça tue la
politique et ça tue surtout la gauche il
y a un type qui a compris quelque chose
qui est plus malin que tous ces excités
c'est François Ruffin qui d'un coup se
déclare sociale démocrate comme Bernard
cazen serait bien de méditer plutôt que
d'essayer de faire franchement ce coup
d'éclat permanent vous émettez bien
méditer au lieu de faire des coups de
clopes permanents
alors juste pour revenir à ce que vous
disiez moi je prends le truc comme
comme Jean-Luc Mélenchon aura carido et
Alexis Corbière n'aura pas dans le truc
comme voilà un signe de loyauté voilà
moi je le prends comme ça on va finir
par voilà Julien ou double au pire Henry
Dumont qui veut prendre la parole euh
d'apprendre les yeux
alors est-ce que c'est normal de parler
comme ça un député non non pas du tout
ah oui c'est pas mais au-delà du député
avec lui que la
c'est le premier point c'est déjà de
dire que c'était voilà un moment
peut-être de tension et qui peut
s'expliquer parce qu'en fait vous aviez
en face de vous vous n'aviez pas un
invité comme tous les autres vous aviez
probablement un ancien collègue un ami
quelqu'un que vous connaissez qui avait
donc des liens beaucoup plus forts que
un simple invité qui venait une fois
tous les ans ou tous les six mois ici
sur sur TPMP donc en fait c'est une
dispute entre deux personnes qui se
connaissent et disputes entre des
personnes qui se connaissent sont
beaucoup plus fortes qu'entre des
personnes qui se connaissent pas par
nature et exactement ce serait pas passé
entre nous non mais voilà bien sûr vous
faites la même chose ici ça se passe
papa surtout que ce serait pas sincère
en santé au fait qu'il y avait aussi une
sorte de sincérité d'ailleurs parce
qu'il y a une sorte d'incompréhension et
le spectacle qui a été renvoyé on va
être très clair c'est un spectacle qui
est désolé mais qui est désolé pour tout
le monde désolé
pour l'image que ça renvoie des médias
en France désolé après par tous les
raccourcis qui ont pu être fait sur ce
qui est dit sur ce qui peut être fait
ici ce qui peut être le travail des
députés à l'Assemblée salle même il y a
encore quelques secondes qu'on entendait
oui mais vous à l'Assemblée nationale
vous donnez pas le bon exemple pardon
mais le rôle d'un député c'est justement
de débattre nous notre quasiment notre
instrument de travail c'est la voix
c'est le fait de pouvoir s'expliquer
s'exprimer alors on le fait mais sans
insulte
très clair en tout cas au sein de
l'Assemblée nationale tous ceux qui font
longtemps
et ça fait partie d'une toute toute
toute petite minorité mais en réalité
c'est les insultes par exemple 1500
euros 1500 quelque soit l'insulte bah
c'est les insultes qui sont considérées
comme un signe
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
vous me faites le tout pour moi de 3000
on va voir ce qu'on peut faire on va
vous faire un petit restaurant
mais c'est l'hypocrisie absolue des
insoumis qui sont quasiment avec table
ouverte ici sur TPMP qui sont toujours
invités
franchement poussé dans les
retranchements dans ce que vous avez à
dire ici ils ont jamais été mis face à
leur contradiction c'est des pros de
l'indignation permanent c'est ce que
disait car le livre c'est les premiers à
défendre même la défendable à faire des
justices pour Adama des collectifs comme
ça et là aussi bah ils sont en train de
défendre l'indéfendable enfin pardon
mais il a fait quoi dans sa vie Louis
Boyard il a créé quel emploi
alors on va on va se voir ensemble
de créer son truc tout seul moi
j'aimerais bien avoir beaucoup plus de
capitaine d'industrie comme ça en France
alors oui il faut avoir savoir c'est pas
une concentration des médias très bien
il y a une commission d'enquête au Sénat
déjà fait au sénateurs
le seul job qui l'a activé c'est celui
de dealer de drogue au bout d'un moment
ça va 2 secondes quoi le leçon moralisme
et c'est cette indignation permanente ce
cette volonté de l'extérieur de toujours
jouer sur la division des Français les
uns contre eux parce que ça va se
stratégie ouais du buzz permanent et
c'est comme ça qu'il gagne c'est comme
ça qu'ils veulent gagner quand même
juste rappeler un truc parce que
personne ne dit rien j'ai cru comprendre
que Monsieur Boyard voulait aller en
juillet
je rappelle que Jean-Luc Mélenchon a été
condamné pour un joueur public non mais
juste qu'on le sache donc à un moment
donné ceux qui jouent ça me fera encore
un peu le verbe mauvais se font
rattraper par la réalité politique comme
par la réalité judiciaire donc ceux qui
ont déjà été condamnés pour un joueur
public et je pense que c'est la gêne de
Mélenchon ne vont pas venir nous
expliquer je ne sais je ne sais trop
quoi je crois que ce sont les limites de
ce discours vraiment moi je crois que
vraiment si on veut retenir quelque
chose au plan politique moi je suis venu
que pour ça pour dire ce que je pense en
tant que responsable et dirigeant Polyte
à côté du prof de sport
c'est que je pense qu'on ne peut plus
continuer à dégrader le débat public
comme ça on ne peut pas avoir un groupe
politique qui prend nos tâches la gauche
qui méritent un jour de gouverner et
d'être représenté par de meilleurs
personnalités de meilleur députés plus
présentables au sens politique du terme
qui joue autre chose que l'hystérie
permanente l'insulte l'affrontement sans
mesure tout en se jouant du système on
venant chez Baba en venant chez Hanouna
en venant partout je pense que je pense
qu'il faut vraiment revenir à quelque
chose de plus serein parce qu'on ne peut
pas continuer sur un climat comme ça
ils vont revenir je vous la fais quoi
demain ils vont se réunir je vous donne
le tarif ils vont suspendre leur
participation à TPMP chez Hanouna
suspension je doute alors là je mets
habillé moi je parie pas mais je mets
des symbolique
j'ai que la France insoumise et les
dirigeants de ce parti de cette de ce
que j'ai rien contre
les émissions parce que ça fait un peu
beaucoup de monde chez Bolloré côté
Julien Oullins
je vais vous parler avec sincérité
également Cyril
on se connaît
mieux que toi peut-être mieux que
quelque chose
c'est le générique obligatoire
Jean-Marie Bigard je vais vous dire la
vérité peut-être mieux que les trois
autres parce qu'on a pas toujours été
copains avec Siri c'est vrai et au début
de notre relation médiatique ouais c'est
vrai bien sûr on s'est échangé des mots
je vous ai traité de pitres rappelez
vous et ensuite ça s'est dissipé et très
clairement j'ai vu que les émissions
face à Baba ou TPMP était des endroits
où la liberté d'expression
était tout simplement sanctuarisé ou
toutes les opinions pouvaient s'exprimer
librement je me rappelle des débats de
la présidentielle ou Marine Le Pen a pu
s'exprimer sur le fond et tous les
autres candidats ont pu exprimer sur le
fond et intéressés des millions de
Français chose que les chaînes
ancestrales n'ont jamais pu faire bien
sûr donc il faut vous remercier Cyril
est-ce que je pense que Cyril ce que
n'accepte pas certains à la fois dans
les médias et quelques politiques aussi
c'est que vous vous êtes peut-être pas
élus mais vous êtes élu par 2 millions
de téléspectateurs tous les soirs et ça
ils ne l'accepte pas vous savez par
combien de personnes a été élu ou Goya
non vous voulez que je vous le dise moi
c'est 20000 25000 euros
9000 personnes
avec Louis Boyard c'est la stratégie de
la victimisation permanente c'est la
provocation c'est le buzz permanent aux
écoles et de la part c'est un parti qui
est le parti des insultes en chef à
l'Assemblée nationale qui insulte 13
millions de Français des lecteurs du
rassemblement national de nazion de
facho de peste brunes etc à l'Assemblée
mais on se prend mais on en prend des
vertes et des femmes mûres et là
de retourner en Afrique
quand on fait de la politique
c'est qu'on accepte d'être chahuté sur
les plateaux de télé qu'on accepte
d'être chahuté par les électeurs
monsieur riansipel un exemple qui nous
relie tous les deux vous m'avez traité
de [ __ ] après l'affaire du voile en
2019 est-ce que je suis allé pleurer ma
mère ou appeler Amnesty International
non c'est le jeu politique c'est une
insulte c'est brutale pour autant encore
une fois j'ai pas convoqué une
commission
[Rires]
[Musique]
il n'aime pas la contradiction si la
peur d'être chahuté faut pas se
présenter devant les électeurs il faut
faire autre chose
le mot [ __ ] est un mot employé par le
plus grand écrivain et philosophe
français du 20e siècle Jean-Paul Sartre
qui ont fait une analyse beaucoup
littéraire alors tout à fait
je peux insulter un député de [ __ ]
non mais vous êtes libre
mais comme
mais comme dit aussi le même philosophe
j'en porte ça c'est pas le Sartre vous
expliquer parce que vous êtes libre vous
êtes aussi responsable alors on va on va
revenir sur la saison autre chose
un commentaire aussi parce que c'est
alors il pleut il porte plein de contre
nous à Louis Boyard vous allez voir ce
qu'on a la plainte et exactement Gilles
pour un jour public avec constitution de
partie civiles un joueur public envers
une personne chargée d'une mission de
service public il a dit aussi ils sont
tweet il a mis quoi le tweet alors le
tweet qui est totalement surréaliste
on lâche pour le lire et il dit qu'il
porte plainte avec une pensée pour les
millions de personnes
insulter insulter chaque fois que Touche
pas à mon poste invite l'extrême droite
et qu'elle a tenu des propos racistes et
islamophobes sur leurs émissions voilà
donc ça veut dire qu'on l'extrême droite
c'est mieux qu'elle a tenu des propos et
donc on doit on doit appeler louboyard
quand on invite quelqu'un maintenant
c'est lui
on le saura donc il veut bien qu'on
invite la France insoumise qu'on invite
tous les parties mais pas dans
rassemblement national je vais faire un
peu de fiction politique je vous fais à
Paris aussi que à partir d'aujourd'hui
Louis Boyard devient un problème pour
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et la France
insoumise très clairement parce que ce
garçon apparaît incontrôlable voilà ce
que je pense je commente pas le reste il
fait ce qu'il veut
que j'analyse l'idée que ce garçon ce
député va poser problème il est un peu
la cendre une Rousseau